[Music]
um
[Music]
before we start i wanted to uh thank the
musicians from the yale school of music
there you are
uh i wish we could do this
i wish we could do this at every press
conference i'm not sure if you're
available we also have some over at the
police station
um dean blocker i think you were going
to come up and say there are a few words
about
about your program
thank you
thank you mayor elicker and president
salovey
our quartet today
represents
many many many groups from yale that
participate in the community
i can say for
this quartet and for many others
that they learn as much from working in
the community as they give
and that's the great magic of what we do
here
for those of us who live here a long
time but for our students who live here
for four or five years
the music and schools program
at yale
with which these ladies are affiliated
serves around 1200 students in the
public schools
and
these young artists
have soloed with
new york phil the soul phil
all around the world can you imagine
being a 10 year old and studying with
one of them
but what they would tell you is they're
enriched by the lives of these young
people that they work with and that we
work with in this community
so
mayor ellicor and those of you who are
representing the new haven organizations
that host us
and help us enable these interactions
where
we not only can bring hope but receive
hope
we thank you and we look forward to the
years ahead where these programs grow
and are enriched and i want to
especially thank
christina lee our cellist rihanna heath
the violist
and kate arndt and anna lee are
violinists it's a great privilege to be
here and to open up this momentous
occasion thank you mr mayor
thank you um and uh before we start uh
some remarks i wanted to make some
acknowledgments uh and i'm gonna try to
do this with uh
my eyes are just looking around the room
i see alder furlo i see alder sabin
alder de cola of course president walker
myers is here
other alders alden marks good to see you
all the marks
any other alders
senator martin looney
is here state representatives or state
senators
good to see you
i also notice dr brown
dr bertolino from gateway dr berlino
from southern
and uh
garrett is here from the chamber of will
from the greater new haven
community foundation
i believe dr camille may be here as well
uh many other people i'd also like to
thank all of the people that are and
acknowledge your presence that will call
me later on
telling me that i forgot to acknowledge
your presence
today is a historic moment uh it's a
historic moment this is a really big
deal
today yale president peter salovey
board of all his president taisha walker
myers
and i are announcing a historic
commitment between yale university and
the city of new haven that will see the
university contribute an additional 52
million dollars in voluntary payments to
the city of new haven over the next six
years
and partner with the city in an effort
to build a more equitable new haven for
all
this is the most significant commitment
that yale university has ever made to
the city and i'm grateful for peter
salve your partnership and your team's
partnership in making this happen i'd
like to turn it over to you to make some
remarks thanks
[Applause]
well thank you mayor ellker i appreciate
those warm
remarks and it is so wonderful to see so
many of you here today
uh i won't try to acknowledge everybody
just a few
uh first of all i'm delighted to be here
with you mayor
and the board of alders
particularly
president taisha walker meyers
state senate president
martin looney
so many neighbors and friends with us
today just one shout out and that is to
a special friend henry fernandez who
really helped shepherd uh this day this
agreement forward and i really
appreciate your
obviously my home team i thank them
every day for the hard work and
partnership that they provide uh at yale
university
so i'm a longtime resident of this city
41 years this year
and i've been faculty member for about
36 years of
of those
41 and i'm just deeply grateful
that today we can be together to honor
and deepen
yells strong enduring relationship with
the city of new haven
the new commitments that we're
announcing today
are informed by decades of collaboration
between members of yale and the new
haven communities
and it is particularly meaningful
that we are launching these new
initiatives as we prepare to emerge
from a pandemic
at this critical inflection point
yale and new haven
are making an emphatic statement
an emphatic statement about our bond
we're choosing to work together to make
the most of this remarkable moment in
the city's history
like never before
new haven is poised for accelerated
expansion
and inclusive growth
the population is growing along with the
city's promising innovation and economic
infrastructure
from new developments such as 101
college street to flourishing
residential commercial and research
spaces
our city is entering a new era an era
that i haven't seen in my 41 years here
and i'm grateful to the governor for the
state's role in encouraging and
supporting private investment here in
new haven projects like 101 college
street
we have an extraordinary opportunity
to position new haven
for sustained inclusive development
across every neighborhood
so as an anchor institution and the
city's largest employer
yale is proud proud to join new haven
and the state of connecticut
in increasing investments in our home
city
first
yale is extending its lead as the
institution that makes the largest
annual voluntary contribution of any u.s
college or university to its home city
we're increasing yale's voluntary
contribution as you heard to new haven
by 52 million
over the next six years 52 million
dollars over the next six years
this equates to over 135 million
in our total voluntary payments
to support for example our libraries
the education of our children
many vital city services
combined with funding from the state's
new pilot program
continue continued contributions by the
private sector federal support
we will make a tremendous positive
difference
in this city
mentioning pilot let me take a moment
to thank senator looney for his vision
and creativity and rethinking
the pilot program in a way that has
greater impact
[Applause]
so in addition to the increase in our
voluntary payment
yale will also gradually offset the loss
in tax revenues if the university should
take properties off the tax roll
to create facilities for teaching
and research
we have an innovative strategy that will
allow yale
to provide long-term benefits both to
the university and the city
through our growth while ensuring that
new haven does not lose out on tax
revenue in the short term
although our financial support is
important
yale is committing
more than just dollars today
we've all seen how american cities have
faced a host of challenges
many of which were exacerbated by the
coveted pandemic
so we're establishing
a new center for inclusive growth
to help address these problems
the center will examine develop and
implement new strategies for growing the
city's economy to the benefit of all new
haven residents
it will complement work that is being
done by the community foundation for
greater new haven by concor
next haven collab
black business alliance new haven
innovation collaborative and many other
organizations concerned
about this challenge
so i've asked professor
kerwin charles the indra nui dean of the
yale school of management to launch this
effort and he is with us
today there he is in the back
[Applause]
so he'll have the help of an advisory
committee of university city and
community leaders
and we will bring together yale's
scholarly strengths to bear on issues
at our front door at our city's front
door
the center for inclusive growth will
demonstrate the power of our partnership
with new haven
in action
so of course the center will be opening
in a city that has been undergoing a
wonderful renaissance over the years
artistic cultural and dining
destinations have emerged across our
city
generating economic development inviting
more people to discover
our vibrant our vibrant community so i'm
delighted
that another element of our plan
our partnership together
creates a new public space where friends
and neighbors can gather
by converting high street between chapel
and elm streets into a pedestrian
walkway
free of vehicle access we'll foster an
attractive social hub near iconic and
city landmarks that everyone
can enjoy
just to be clear the city will continue
to own the street
yale will redevelop
and design this space
and fund the renovation of it into a
pedestrian mall
so the new innovations i'm sorry the new
investments we're launching
represent a major step forward
in yellow's enduring commitment to new
haven at the same time we will continue
to support an array of existing yelp
programs
expected to total over an additional 100
million dollars in contributions
over the next six years
so for example new haven promise which
provides scholarships for the city's
public school students to attend any
university in connecticut will continue
to be an investment focus for yale the
yale university homebuyer program that
helps our employees purchase homes in
the city will continue to be supported
new haven works which offers job
training and placement and other
services continues to be a focus each of
these initiatives including
contributions to the downtown
business improvement district cultural
events
and other local causes helps create a
stronger and more resilient community
together community where we all
can live we all can work where we can
feel that partnership between the
university
and the city itself
i believe that our actions can exemplify
how institutions of higher education can
continue to partner
with their home cities to serve the
common good and i hope we serve as an
inspiration
to others i'm so grateful
to join you join all of you particularly
mayor ellker in writing the next chapter
in yale and new haven's shared history
and i can't wait
to get to work on all that lays ahead of
us
hand in hand
we will create
an exciting and prosperous future
for everyone here for everyone in our
city and for those who will come after
us thank you all for being here
mayor ellicor thank you for your support
[Applause]
thank you uh peter for your partnership
and your leadership and commitment to
the city of new haven uh peter and i
have gotten to know each other quite
well over the past uh two years and to
think back on our first meeting and how
far we've come
in
in our trust for each other but i think
more importantly the representation of
uh the university and the city's trust
and collaboration
is a testament to you and your team's
willingness to
to really work hard to get this across
the finish line thank you mayor and uh
absolutely phil the same way about you
and your team thank you
um i'd also like to thank both teams
that have made this possible
to the
yale team
you have worked
tirelessly
and come to the table with openness
and honesty
and to our city team michael gormany
kevin alvarez sean madison sue
weisselberg a volunteer
mike piscatelli
thank you for expanding your work to
include this very important project
and to henry
the lead on the city's team
who has volunteered hours and hours of
your time your wisdom your expertise
over this past year thank you for what
you've helped us all accomplish together
i spoke with peter last night and we
both felt that it was very important to
acknowledge the work that you have done
and to ask you to to share some words
with all of us henry
[Applause]
uh thank you uh thank you mayor um
my family thanks you as well for our
being able to
uh get their husband and dad back after
a year of uh
of this effort but it it was uh it was
wonderful i do want to give
i want to echo what the mayor said about
the teams on on both sides here um it
was wonderful
uh to uh to work with with all of you
but i want to give a special thanks to
uh jack callahan from yale who's a son
of new haven and an honest negotiating
partner on the other side thank you
kevin
so um
i want to start by just talking a little
bit about what we did
so we spent time
understanding each other's positions
it was apparent that over the years as
people changed in offices and new actors
emerged
both relationships and understandings
between the university and the city
weren't present
i don't mean that everyone
became friends through this process and
that certainly was not our goal
but we were able to explain our
positions and understand each other's
goals and interests
i think yale came to understand that new
haven was addressing structural problems
inherent in how
state law treats cities and taxes city
residents
the city's team came to understand how
yale sees its growth and how it is
balancing competing demands within its
own institution
we spent some time as a group also
discussing issues that are far bigger
than either the city or the university
these issues include matters of racial
justice and economic disparity
that have built up over centuries in our
city and our country
and the recent ramifications of these
issues in the context of covet 19
climate change and the protest movements
around policing across the country and
the globe
and while these issues are bigger than
any one of us or any either the city or
the university that doesn't mean that we
can ignore
history
or that we can ignore equity or the
disparities that are obvious for all of
us in our city
as
president salovey mentioned we sought to
tackle three significant issues
first is the amount of funding that goes
from the university to the city
involuntary payments
and i just want to be really clear about
what we're talking about in the first
year
over 23 million dollars will go from the
university to the city
it will go up every year over the course
of five years and then it will drop in
year six which i suggest to the mayor
uh would be a good time to start
negotiating before you get there
sorry
now that we're done
there's a big red light in year six pay
attention to it
um
as a result of this agreement yale now
contributes more than any other
university to its hometown
in the past different universities could
quibble about whether they were paying
more
or how to count one kind of payment
structure over another
there is no longer anything to quibble
about
yale's annual contributions do not have
anything close to them
i firmly believe however that other
universities
should see this as the new standard
we are in the midst of a global pandemic
in a time of great economic disparity
where anti-democratic forces use these
tragedies to try to divide us
in this moment
other well-known universities around the
country can only truly be great if they
try to beat what we have done and reset
again the standard but for for today
i feel good
about the new standard that we have set
second is the issue of taxable
properties
connecticut cities have historically
relied on property taxes to pay their
bills
indeed it has been the only major tool
that they control
this has created a negative town gown
dynamic
between new haven and yale
basically forever
because of the hard work of senator
looney
and the entire new haven delegation
tiered pilot is now a reality
this new relationship between the city
and yale is possible in part because of
tiered pilot
specifically
yale will make payments to the city
for any properties
taken off the tax rolls
at the full amount
for three years and then in declining
amounts for another 10 years
because of the combination of pilot and
yale's commitment the city will now be
whole for years after any conversion of
property to tax exempt
that takes care of the short and medium
term
and in the long term we believe that
growth at the university
for instance in the sciences
will help create tax paying buildings
for businesses and good paying jobs
third
we recognize the issues of disparity
that i mentioned earlier
to tackle these the university and the
city will work together at the center
for inclusive growth
and as
the president and mayor
as the president said and the mayor will
say
i'm excited for the leadership of dean
kerwin charles
this center will not simply study
the problems but instead we'll use best
research to facilitate the city and the
university's work together to address
real issues in our neighborhoods
those issues that affect low-income
people african-americans latinos
immigrants and refugees in our community
the most
including
climate change
access to high-speed internet
and if we
recall over the last 18 months we saw
the lack of high-speed internet play out
with our school children dramatically
also jobs affordable housing and a
myriad of other needs
the simple idea is that we can build a
city
and the people
the simple idea
is that we can build a city that grows
and benefits both yale university in the
center of our community and the people
across the city of all backgrounds and
all neighborhoods who love this city and
call it home
in five or six years the city and yale
can re-evaluate we probably got some
things right and may have gotten some
things wrong
they need may need to be more aggressive
in some areas and back off in others
now i do want to say a word about the
street
about high street
certainly yale is interested in having
high street operate as no longer a
street for cars
but we agreed early on
that we would do so differently than
done previously
high street will remain a public
thoroughfare
legally owned by the city of new haven
yale will design it in consultation with
the city specifically to ensure that it
is a place for all new haveners whether
walking or on bicycles
whether studying at yale or at hill
house
we look forward to a beautiful new
destination that welcomes all of us and
guests from around the world
uh finally having volunteered for this
role i ask only in return that the city
and the university see this agreement as
a starting point
it can be the first step in a new way of
working together
or
we can see it as a series of
transactions it is i believe a fair
uh set of transactions and in five years
the parties will need to get together to
negotiate again
but my hope is that we have assembled
what we've assembled here
shows that we can do much bigger things
together
that we can work together to ensure that
tiered pilot stays in place and support
uh senator looney in that that we can do
large renewable energy projects together
that make new haven a center of what's
possible
that yale students and students at
wechsler grant
can have ridiculously fast internet
and all of the opportunities that come
with that
because we can work together to cover
our downtown and our neighborhoods with
fiber optics
that we set new standards for growth
that focus on good paying jobs and allow
our residents to benefit equally from
that growth
that we'll be aggressive in rebuilding
neighborhoods
and if we are able to tackle these
bigger things together we can all
rejoice
when a new building is built at yale
just as much as we can rejoice when more
affordable housing is built in one of
our new residential high-rises or one of
our neighborhoods
because cities are great
only when they benefit us all
our city will be great
when we all look out for each other
and then and when
those with power and opportunity
use it to make our city more equal and
just
with that i'd like to say thank you to
the mayor i'll turn over the keys you
can drive the car i'm done
and but thank you thank you for the
opportunity
uh thank you again henry uh you know
this is a real win
for new haven
the new haven community and it's a win
for yale university because what's good
for new haven is good for yale
for years so many people have
contributed to making this moment a
possibility
new haven rising unite here the board of
alders our state delegation faith
leaders residents who have attended
public meetings people who have talked
about it emailed about it written about
it posted on social media about it this
moment is because of your work
without you you would not be we would
not be here today
and president salve and henry went over
the four points of the commitment
and i want to talk a little bit about
what these points actually mean for the
city and yale
uh first the increase in voluntary
payments from the university will amount
to over as peter said 135 million over
the next six years to put this in
perspective yale will be contributing to
the city more over the next six years
than it has in the past twenty years
at a time when the city has been facing
significant financial challenges the
university has not acknowledged that we
need to partner together to address them
yale's increased contribution combined
with the increased pilot payments
championed by our state delegation and
senator looney means that this fiscal
year the city will have received a total
of 59 million in additional
contributions or over 10 percent of our
overall budget that's truly remarkable
and it's an acknowledgment that all
parties
when we work together can accomplish
incredible things
second yale's voluntary offset of the
loss of tax revenues when they take a
property off the tax rolls
for years yale's growth has taken
taxable property off the grand list
putting pressure on the city's budget in
taxpayers it's created a dynamic where
many felt that yale's growth wasn't
benefiting our city
this new innovative approach better
aligns the city and yale's interests and
means that yale's growth benefits our
city not just through more jobs and
economic activity but also by
maintaining its tax revenue
now when yale grows we all benefit
third the block of high street between
elm and chapel in the past the city has
sold public assets to the university
in this commitment we work to accomplish
the goal of making the block of high
street safer for yale constituents and
all community members
in a way that ensures the street remains
a public asset for all to enjoy
not only do we ensure that that property
remains in the public domain but
together we set the right tone the yale
is a part of our community
and finally the center for inclusive
growth while each component of the
commitment announced today is important
i believe the creation of this center in
particular meets this moment in time in
history
when we started the conversation with
yale
it wasn't just about writing a check
it was about how we worked together to
change our city so that opportunities
experienced by some in our community
could be experienced by all
this is a challenge our world
our world is struggling with and yale
has decided to do this work in its own
backyard
in its home new haven
yale's enthusiasm for the center is key
to its success president salve has been
serious not just about this in words but
in who he is asked to take it on with
dean charles who has specific expertise
in intergenerational transmission of
economic status and wealth inequality
did i get that right
mostly mostly
and the fact that yale is contributing
an additional five million dollars to
help start this center
we all know that new haven is growing
and while our team at the city works
very hard to ensure that that growth is
equitable still there is much work ahead
of us so the communities particularly
communities of color who have
historically been under-resourced will
benefit from this growth
the center for inclusive growth will set
the tone that the university and the
city
work together to ensure that everyone in
new haven has the opportunity to thrive
there are vast opportunities here for
harnessing both the real and
intellectual capital of the university
through the center and expanding its
impact through partnerships with the
community foundation for greater new
haven other local colleges and
universities and other partners in the
region
taken together today's commitments
fundamentally reset the relationship
between yale and the city of new haven
and they put the city on a more
sustainable financial path and they
acknowledge that the university and city
are committing to ensuring that everyone
in our city has the opportunity to
thrive
this would not have been possible
without the partnership and long work of
years and years
by president
taisha walker myers
and i invite her up
[Applause]
thank you good afternoon um i want to
thank the mayor and president salovey
and mr fernandez for laying out the
details of the deal because now i don't
have to do that
um
but i think it's really important that
i'm here to speak for the thousands of
residents
that work with the unions and elected
officials
that brought awareness to the things
that we need in new haven that never
took their foot off of the gas that
continue to force the conversations and
the greatest part of the agreement today
for me is that those residents finally
finally have an opportunity to see that
gail actually heard what they were
saying this is a great start
i'm looking forward to
the partnership and the part of the
partnership where we're having the real
conversations about the things that our
residents need i'm looking for the
uncomfortable parts of the conversations
that will happen because anytime i'm
involved that you know come up sometime
about what our residents really need i'm
looking forward to the part of the
conversation where we actually have
results about bringing people in this
city out of poverty that's what i'm
looking forward to because i think
that's really important and this
agreement it is historic as the mayor
said it's historic because we actually
had unions
elected officials
and community members all working
together
over a number of years saying yo please
hear our cry
we have needs that we really need help
addressing and yell stepped up and said
we're hearing you we're listening
but a partnership is not over once an
agreement is signed it goes far beyond
that so today is historic and i'm
actually really proud to stand here i
don't come to many things if i don't
believe in it
but anything that i'm involved in i
won't take my foot off the gas i won't
stop pressing the real issues i won't
stop speaking for the residents that
felt like they never had a voice up
until now i'll continue doing that and i
know that yale here you know they hear
um that call i work with them in many
different capacities and i'm always the
same way i might add in all little
spaces but for me in order to really be
celebrating and we are celebrating
because this is historic this is great
for our city
but the things that i really care about
because i grew up here too
i am one of those residents that felt
like you know you get what you get from
yale and you can't get anything else so
i'm standing here today for all those
people that didn't have faith that a
real partnership was going to happen so
it's my responsibility to make sure that
happened and i won't stop i just want to
let you know now
it will get uncomfortable but we will
get results thank you
i think there's a lot of us in this room
that can uh
testify to that discomfort that
sometimes we feel when talking with
president walker meyers uh dean charles
would you mind coming up and saying a
few words about the center
[Applause]
i'm delighted to be here
i am grateful
to have been included in the team on the
yell side
and even more grateful that over the
course of the last several months
we on the yale side and i speak for
myself personally have gotten a chance
to learn to meet to know to befriend
our partners
on the new haven side
i say partners because it is my
conviction and i believe the view
of the yale side if we call it that more
generally
that yale's thriving
is tied up with new haven success and
vice versa yes
i'm stimulated by where we have
reached today the point we've read
during the course of the last several
months
various things occurred to me
i for example learned
about activities in which yale is
already engaged
and has been engaged for many years
scattered across the university
we just saw the music program about
which i previously knew nothing
they're similar opportunities
but we are activities
whereas yale has been engaged in
activities in this
university-wide fashion
any honest assessment
of the city's needs
and this historical moment
make clear it seems to me
that there is opportunity and space
opportunity and space for activities
that foster inclusive growth
what is meant by that term
what is inclusive growth
obviously there's a part of it that is
about growth
by growth i think we jointly mean
vibrant and robust and thriving economic
activity
yes
but i think jointly we don't merely mean
that
we mean thriving robust economic
activity
that promotes health and safety for
example
it is sustainable for example
yes
but even more than that
the reason we include as a group
the inclusive piece
is that we are jointly committed to the
idea
that such growth as occurs in our
community
the benefits of that growth
must be diffusely spread across our
communities neighborhoods
our communities racial groups
it must benefit whatever growth occurs
all of new hair
so when i think about
what we might do on the inclusive growth
side
i think
there are multiple opportunities here
to enlarge upon ongoing programs
and to institute new ones
enlarge upon ongoing programs and
implement new ones
with the aim
guided by the principle i might say
that whatever we
new initiatives we start
have the following features
that they be truly collaborative
truly collaborative
that they be genuinely respectful
which is to say
that whereas the yale team might in a
particular case interact with new haven
partners on a particular problem
we will not approach our conversation
with the presumption that all the ideas
rest on the yale side
yes
we believe that there is much to be
learned from genuine collaboration
our collaboration must be respectful
yes
and the hope is that it will be mutually
beneficial
both to yale
and to new haven
the opportunities for this kind of
inclusive activity in my view extend
in every department at yale every school
every program i'm the dean of the yale
school of management
and i speak to you as a representative
of a single school
were other deans present i'm confident
that each of them could point to some
set of activities ongoing or
contemplated yes that would advance the
ends i have just described
but if i may take a moment to speak
about my school
and how i envision
where it sits in the new center we are
launching
i believe that the yale school of
management
has
an outsized imperative
and similarly outsized opportunity
to profitably and meaningfully
contribute in the way i've just
described
why this outsized imperative of what do
i speak what i mean by that
our imperative is outsized and our
opportunity is outsized
because of the combination of our
peculiar distinctive mission at the yale
school of management
the special expertise interests and
talents of our students
and the research and scholarly focus of
our faculty
a brief word about the mission the
school of management is the only
business school in the country that is
organized on a mission that says it
seeks to train leaders for business
and society it says
and society
if that is truly our motto
if that is truly our animating value
let's begin by trying to help this
society
the community in which we live
where our neighbors and friends are
every day
let's begin there yes
this special motto and set of values of
the school is reflected in the kinds of
students
who come to the school
the kinds of students who come to the
school
animated by
not only a desire to be successful
business people
but to transform the world in a
productive
useful and meaningful way to the benefit
of multiple stakeholders
the mayor knows a bit wherever i speak
because some of our students and our
graduates go on to do things like become
mayor of their city
talk to me yeah
so the mayor knows about that
so we have mission we have the values of
our students
those students also possess certain
kinds of human capital expertise and
energy that will benefit our city and
community
our students
can have internships
here at the city
our students can work on research
projects imagined by the city team our
students can engage in work with
non-profit organizations
conversations that i have already
started as dean yeah
on the research side
some of the questions the research ideas
that animate our faculty
concern matters that our interest to the
city
we have experts in any number of fields
operations
finance accounting
whose ideas
would be a value to our city
as the growth we all imagine and hope
for occurs in the coming years
the non-profit center
launching arch entrepreneurial activity
social impact investing
i can go on
the precise details of all that will
occur under the umbrella of our new
initiative
and not yet clear
but i can assure you
that i and we collectively
embark upon that mission with great
enthusiasm
and i personally have profound
confidence
that although we'll have an
uncomfortable conversation here and
there i'm cool with that
that our success is assured
if we bring to that effort
the effort of collaboration
friendship openness
and energy that we brought to our
conversations over the last year
thank you very much mayor
uh so one of the speakers stole my run
of show but i'm pretty sure that we are
at our last uh speaker here
and when you think about over this past
two years what we've accomplished out of
city it is quite remarkable
senator looney
your leadership
i always talk about how i sat down at
the greek olive with you
just about two years ago and you said i
had this idea
this has dramatically
benefited new haven but
what we don't often talk about in new
haven is how many other towns and cities
across our state
have received a significant increase in
the investment because of senator
looney's work
those cities and
towns are
ones of need and so the impact that you
had on our city is incredible but the
impact on our state as well to senator
looney maybe you can finish us off here
thank you so much mayor this is truly
uh an historic day uh with this
announcement between the city of new
haven and yale university i want to
congratulate mayor elicker
president salve
their negotiating teams certainly
dean charles mr callahan on the yale
side
henry fernandez the visionary leader on
the city side also like to give a shout
out to my dear friend of 35 years sue
weisselberg who was on the uh the city
team and sue as uh as many know
a number of years ago she served as
counsel very effectively as counsel to
our house democratic caucus in the
general assembly and then also directed
uh the school construction program for
the city of new haven for many years uh
which also uh set a mark for the state
in which a 1.5 billion
program to
to revolutionize new haven's physical
plant of its schools of which about 1.2
billion was paid by the state of
connecticut
in that partnership and
her management of that inspired great
confidence but
what we see here today as has been
discussed is a uh
is a new day and uh one of the things i
think that's uh that's most important uh
early in the 2021 session uh president
salabe said to me in in a conversation
if the state of connecticut
is willing to enhance its commitment to
the city of new haven
yale will certainly respond in kind
and do the same
state of connecticut has done that and
today yale announces that it is also
doing that and i think that that is a is
a meeting of promises and commitments
and aspirations on both sides uh
president salve is someone i've known
and admired for a long time i think he's
done a superb job as yale president
we've developed a close working
relationship but uh years in fact a
couple of decades before that uh i work
closely as a board member the fair haven
community health center uh with his wife
wonderfully public spirited uh and
brilliant woman martha moretz so please
say hello to tomorrow for me but uh and
at the time they lived within the
service area of the fairhaven health
center they lived in in fair haven so uh
peter salovey knows the view of new
haven from elsewhere than hillhouse
avenue because he has lived that too so
i wanted to thank him for that again the
uh the pilot program that we were able
to uh reconfigure uh in the in this
session was something that had been
percolating for a while as uh mayor
eliquid and i strategized about it a
couple of years ago at the uh the greek
olive which is defunct but the program
of course is not
and the
uh what it amounted to was a recognition
that there are that pilot needed a more
expanded constituency and the way to do
that was to involve more towns in pilot
eligibility and the approach that we
found to do that was to look at
equalized net grand list per capita and
there are a large number of relatively
poor communities in the state notably in
eastern connecticut
that are struggling even though they may
not have a lot of tax exempt property or
pilot eligible property but to the
extent that they that they do
if they have a net grant list per capita
of under 100 000
as of course all the major cities do
they will get fifty percent
reimbursement under pilot for the uh
tax-exempt college and hospital and also
state property uh for those in the next
tier uh between a hundred and two
hundred thousand dollars of tax exempt
property uh those communities will get
forty percent and then those over 200
000 in net grand list per capita will
get 30
now again every tier is above the
current level of reimbursement which is
about 25
so uh one of the reasons we were able to
develop broad-based consensus on this
that even the towns in the uh in the
lowest tier uh we're going to get a
significant increase over what pilot had
been uh most recently so
we believe that this will be will be
transformative uh coupled with the uh
the increase in funding for uh for yale
over the life of this program especially
uh yale's commitment to continue to pay
taxes on properties newly taken off uh
the tax rolls for a period of time
this is something that uh
is going to result in what we hoped it
would do and i also want to especially
thank my colleagues on this especially
representative tony walker of new haven
who is of course the the house
chair of the general assembly's
appropriations committee in that
position she was critical
in this enterprise and also the speaker
of the house matt ritter who represents
hartford uh and his support for this of
course was was critical in his city of
course is a major beneficiary of the
reconfigured pilot uh as well so again
i'm glad we were able to to come to this
day
i had confidence from the very beginning
that we would
because of the people involved
and the honesty and the earnestness
and the solidity of their commitment so
i think we have a great deal to
celebrate today thank you all
[Applause]
[Applause]
you